[Music]
two days before the Obama administration
ended its Department of Education
released a report showing the
administration's most expensive
education initiative had failed badly
the school return around program was
meant to dramatically improve the
nation's lowest-performing schools the
Obama team sent billions of dollars to
the struggling districts running the
struggling schools this is the
foundation of countless previous local
state and federal school turnaround
efforts this final report found that the
schools that got the money when compared
to similar schools that didn't get the
money
saw no improvement in test scores and
high school graduation rates or college
attendance none yes billions and
taxpayer dollars were squandered but
more importantly millions of low-income
kids are still assigned to persistently
underperforming schools now the new
federal education law encourages States
to use new approaches to this problem
and the Trump administration is pushing
school choice but whatever we do
remember the future of millions of
disadvantaged kids is at stake here
great schools and great educators can do
so much we just have to do something
differently to learn more about my take
on education reform check the links in
the description below also let us know
what other topics you'd like a EEI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds